now before you get back to season 2 the
little thing called dirty dancing to
wrap up our those rehearsals insane yeah
they're insane because for me whose most
Awkward person the world has never
danced before it's literally so crazy
and I started yesterday actually with
Holt proudest he's playing Johnny he's
awesome and a professional Broadway
dancer and the posters are from the
Pussycat Dolls and I was so nervous and
thankfully they were super super nice to
me like they were like cheering me on
they walk in and they like give Nicole
like this like really complicated combo
that I had learned like a week earlier
and I was like I'm gonna nail this and
like she's gonna be like freaking out oh
she's a nice person and then she's like
like nothing the second I'm like are you
ready to do the lift I won't ever be
ready I want to like have somebody sign
a contract thing I won't die because if
anybody could like kill not only myself
that's a guy I'm like everybody in the
room with us it would be me by doing
that I'd like fall in such a complex way
that everybody would just die so I'm
gonna get fired from this do this
interview I really Wow